ben you know that i despise you and that
i want you and all people on earth to be
miserable right
sure i hate doing leslie's job i'm
filling in for a person who smiles 90
of the time tom can you please help me
please
or just do it come on little sparkle
don't give up
what does leslie always say i don't know
weird stuff about waffles
she says you get out of a job what you
put into it you just need to find a
project you're passionate about andy
look at this little guy
he's such a little run hey there hey tom
look
oh i just had five cats on me at once
you want to come in here trying to break
my record
that's okay andy i think i'm gonna keep
my distance don't want none of that
animal dander interacting with this
cashmere
what's your end game here my dear this
is only temporary until i find a way to
keep the shelter open without cutting
the park's budget
hey what if i threw together a pet
adoption in one of our parks would that
be cool
april that would be the coolest thing
since nsync aerosmith
and nelly performed together at the
super bowl halftime show
i think i may have found a project i'd
actually enjoy doing
helping these cats and dogs they should
be rewarded for not being people
i hate people huh i hate
talking to people about things this is a
nightmare
ah i'm grouchy
mighty putty
what are we doing we didn't get a single
thing that ben told us too
sure we did we got the marshmallow
shooter
i don't think that's on the list but i
want it i want it too
but i also kind of want my own fork just
cause you eat really slow which is cute
but also
super annoying
fine what what's wrong nothing it's just
adults are boring and i hate them and i
don't want to buy all this stupid boring
adult stuff and become boring adults
hey listen to me yes we're gonna get a
dish rack and shower curtains and a
cutting board
but if you think for one second i'm not
also gonna get that marshmallow shooter
so that i can shoot you in the face with
marshmallows when you're asleep then
you're the dumbest woman i know
you're gonna make me cry
how's the coolest chick ever not good
what do you mean leslie's making us go
on a camping retreat
that's awesome camping's the best
camping sucks
it's super boring and you can see the
stars which i hate
they're creepy okay leslie knope outfit
number eight
babe you look super hot you realize
you've said that
about all of them well she has every
single time cause she is super hot
honestly you need to look hard naked ugh
the suit makes me want to scold a
catholic child
i don't know who ann taylor is but i
hate her and i want to kill her
i have to lead a public forum for the
pawnee commons every day this week
and i hate talking to people ugh i hope
that this prom is exactly
like my senior prom theme my heart will
go on
photo booth with monica lewinsky look
alike after party megan rickerson's
house her parents used to let us drink
as much as we wanted
that's that's where we should have this
after-party
or no we can't because they moved to
prison prom is nothing but a huge party
full of smiling dancing people enjoying
themselves
it's literally my worst nightmare and i
hate punch
hello i am calling on behalf of leslie
knope who is running for city council
is this deirdre splatterfork that is
literally the most beautiful name i have
ever heard
no i don't think we can accept donations
over 50 dollars
i don't really know why you would need
my social security number
but well yeah no you're right i guess i
couldn't hurt to give it to you
it's 2-1-0 absolutely nothing
what are you wearing fine if you don't
want to donate then don't
oh by the way i'm calling from inside
your house
ha ha 100 whoa
this is unbelievable i cannot be stopped
come on now get some money come on april
get in here peace come on do it get some
money i don't care about that prize
but i'm gonna win because i want his
happiness to go away
hey where are you i'm here where are you
we're inside the main entrance near the
sign that says pawnee campground
oh i'm in a totally different place
that's why we can't see each other oh my
god andy i don't even want to be here
the air is too fresh it's disgusting i
can't breathe
there's a brook somewhere that won't
stop babbling shut up
[Music]
hello andy you have to save me i'm
camping with people i work with
hello april hello walk around in circles
like i
am help triangulate the phone call
hello
well we did it we went to prom yay let's
go now
no what are you kidding this is awesome
look around
the bloom of youth like flowers on the
sunset
of an eagle's poetry andy i hate
teenagers
if you give this a chance you're gonna
love it i promise it's like the movie
expendables too
first time hated it second time hated it
third time it was okay but then the
fourth fifth sixth
tenth time i watched it i realized
something
it's just it's not good it's not a good
movie now that i've convinced you
why don't we go dance um i'm gonna go to
the girls bathroom to check the trash
cans for babies but you can dance if you
want
really i love you thank you yeah
are you getting ready for your nightly
skype date with andy in london
you look lovely i'm going to murder you
a thousand times okay
i hope you like deep dish pizza because
there's gonna be a lot more of it in
chicago where we're all gonna be moving
okay no no come on guys take a risk
live on the edge life is an adventure it
is let's do it
no no pawnee is cheap and we like it
here
and chicago seems like there's a lot of
stuff to do in people but
i like to do nothing with no one so
thank you and i love you
but no thank you and i hate you
i love you nice job on the water
fountain
it wasn't me don't deny it i know it
wasn't the nurse
i'm asking you to step up not replacing
leslie
just picking up some slack i don't want
to do things i want to not do things
just like you taught me soundtrack to
pulp fiction
soundtrack to singles soundtrack to
gross point blank why do you have so
many soundtracks
oh well uh i kind of look at it like
it's your favorite director's making a
mixtape just for you
oh oh here's something
benji's cool time summer jams mix oh no
i
probably don't want to listen to that
yes i want to listen to you i want to
listen to it i don't know
we don't need to april shoot
[Music]
don't judge me data had never felt this
way before
of course data had never felt anything
before
but captain picard couldn't help but
note the smile
that crept over his mechanical but
lifelike
face i'm gonna murder you i understand
just one sec
as they walked down the hall into the
bridge
just put all the candy in a bowl or
something what's wrong
did you eat all the candy no did you yes
but that's not what's wrong it's just
seeing all those kids out there
babe
i want to put a babe in you baby andy
you know where i stand on this
yes i would love all the awesome stuff
my body would go through i mean if all
it meant was puking
and getting weird stretch marks and
veins everywhere then sign me up
but at the end we've brought a child
into the world that's disgusting
all right that's basically it water the
plants get the mail
can i read your mail no please don't
fine
oh and um here are the keys and remember
i know don't let tom make a copy that's
right good
i'm paying april 50 bucks to watch my
house while i'm away
i would have asked leslie but i've seen
the way she takes care of her house
plus there's always been a little
distance between me and april
and i thought this would baby i don't
know give us a chance to
get a little closer maybe even i don't
like anne
i guess i kind of hate most things
but i never really seem to hate you
okay so i took extensive notes on ways
to maximize our efficiency because we
can't be just as good as a man we have
to be better
yeah you're totally right let's rock
this april i love you
but i don't need your sarcasm right now
i'm serious let's get rolling i want to
get into some garbage
what i love garbage
you